these newly hatched baby loggerhead
turtles poke their heads out of the sand
and wave hello to their first days on
planet earth loggerheads are found in
the Atlantic Ocean from Newfoundland to
Argentina and in the Pacific from Alaska
to Chile
they're all pre-programmed with the
instruction to crawl out of the sand
directly toward the glimmering lights of
the ocean it's a good thing they start
the trek immediately because there are
no parents there to guide and protect
them these babies could live for decades
or just a few hours if the turtle is
female she may very well return to the
same Beach in 25 years to lay her own
eggs if it's a male he'll never leave
the water again